here's what would happen if you spent a
month on Snake Island
after it's split from Mainland Brazil 11
000 years ago snake Island's reptilian
inhabitants developed Venom five times
more powerful than their Mainland
cousins you think you could survive a
whole month this stuff is potent enough
to kill you in one hour if left
untreated
if you stuck to the Shoreline territory
you'd likely be okay these snakes prefer
to stay deep within the rainforest and
if for some reason you needed cash one
golden Lance head Viper would bring you
about thirty thousand dollars on the
black market Lance head Venom is used in
some blood pressure medications so this
Viper Venom is valuable if you
interfered with poachers bio Pirates or
your 4 000 endangered golden Lance head
Viper Neighbors
you would become the endangered species
so